learn how to build projects using remix
and strappy in this course you'll
discover how to harness the power of
remix a modern react framework to create
Dynamic userfriendly front-end
interfaces and you'll learn how to
integrate strappy a flexible open-
Source headless CMS to efficiently
manage and deliver your content Paul
Brett sofsky developed this course he'll
teach you essential concepts best
practices and practical tips to help you
create seamless scalable web
applications hello you want ful people
at free code Camp I'm excited for this
new tutorial that I'm going to share
with you we're going to learn about
remix strappy and how to combine both of
them together to build things quickly we
first going to start by learning about
what remix is getting started with the
basics then we're going to add strappy
to our remix applications to see how you
can use remix and strappy together so
what is remix remix is a full stack web
development framework created by the
same team that brought us react router
it is also backed by Spotify so you know
it'll be around for a long time more
importantly it allows you to build
amazing user experiences while embracing
the web standards since it's a fullstack
framework you're able to build both your
front end and backend together but as a
new developer or someone who's just
starting out or you just don't have a
lot of time and you want build
applications even faster this is where
strappy comes in strappy is a headless
CMS that allows you to create a API in
minutes it gives you this amazing admin
panel area to manage your data and more
importantly you have a functional API
that comes in with authentication user
management and other great functionality
so to empower us to build cool things
for our clients we going to leverage
remix and strappy together so let's take
a look on what we're going to build
during this tutorial we're going to
cover the basics of remix everything you
need to know to get started with remix
quickly once we learn the basics of
remix we're going to jump in and add our
strappy back end to our remix
application we're going to cover full CR
functionality from creating deleting
updating and getting our data and you'll
be able to visually see your data within
your strappy application which is pretty
cool so let's take a look at all the
things we are going to learn about we're
going to cover remix routing we're going
to take a look at nested routes and
Outlets we're going to also look at how
to create Dynamic routes we're going to
cover how to use loader and action
functions to get data from our strappy
API which will cover full C
functionality including create read
update and delete we also going to take
a look at form validation with side
which is pretty cool and we're going to
learn how to submit forms using remix
including use fetch a function as well
as how to handle errors via error
boundaries and few additional things as
well I hope you're excited about this
tutorial as I'm as much teaching it to
you so with that being said let's jump
right into it and finally before we
start how can you get help well one of
the main ways that you could ask me
questions is actually go to the project
repo that I'm going to have in the
description of the video and you could
click on issues and you could create a
new issue with your question and then I
will be able to see it and give you any
help that you need also if you're
looking for the code snippet that we
reference in the course you will find
them all below here in the readme file
we just have couple of SN
that you will want to have access to
while doing this course and more
importantly while doing this tutorial
you'll be able to ask questions in the
comments for the video on free Cod cam
Channel as well as I'm going to create a
thread on their Forum to be able to
answer questions there as well so let's
jump to it and build cool things before
we get started let's go over some of the
prerequisites although I made this
course with beginners in mind you should
have some basic understanding of basic
programming like a HTML CSS and
JavaScript also you should feel
comfortable around your computer like
opening a terminal and being able to
install basic packages you should have
node installed and that should be enough
with that being said the focus of this
course is to really improve our
understanding of remix and strappy and
that's what we're going to do with that
out of the way let's get started let's
navigate to remix run and click the get
started button we're going to navigate
to this tutorial we're going to start
here because I want everybody to start
with the basics of remix we're going to
do this tutorial together and then I'll
show you how to hook up strappy to this
project the reason why I'm using
documentation is because I want
everybody to feel comfortable that
documentation is your friend and
whenever you get stock these are the
resources that you have available for
you to help you get unstuck so we're
going to work through this together but
if you run into any issues you can
always reference the documentation it is
amazing but with that being said back in
our remix tutorial let's now navigate to
the bottom here where we could see this
generate basic template command and this
is what we're going to use to get
started so I'm going to go ahead and
copy it inside my terminal I already
created a folder for my project I'm
going to go ahead and paste that command
and click enter this is going to go
ahead and start creating our project I'm
just going to keep this the same click
enter and it's going to go ahead and
create your project it's going to ask
you if you want to initialize a new git
repository you could say yes install dep
pendy 1 npm Click yes and it's going to
go ahead and create your project once
your project is installed you could type
LS to see the newly created folder we
could CD into that folder and we could
open our project inside vs code by
running code period and here you are you
have your remix project the most
important part to keep in mind is that
we're going to be working inside this
app directory we have our basic app CSS
we have our data file that came with
this template to allow us to simulate
that we are connected to the database
when we're making our basic requests and
our project starts from this route and
here you see all the basic jsx that will
render our pages and this is just a
starting point and we'll learn more
about this as we continue and we could
run our project by running npm run def
this is going to start our project in
development environment so let's take a
look and see what we have so far so what
do we have here not much because this is
just the beginning of our project but we
have our basic input form and a button
to submit our form with a list of few
items and this is coming from our root.
DSX file which is the entry point to our
application and we'll talk more on this
later but right now as you could see
inside our body element we have our
input and we have our Button as well as
our list items so now that our app is
setup let's take a look at the root
route and adding our link to link to our
stylesheet root. TSX is our root route
and it's typically what is rendered
first and this is where you would put
your layout if you wanted to so here's
our root route and this is where we have
our sidebar we could add additional
elements such as a header or a footer
and an outlet component that would
render all other routes which we'll talk
a little bit more about it but for now
let's take a look how we could add CSS
to our project to import our CSS into
our remix application we're going to use
the links tag you could read more about
it in the documentation we're also going
to need to get its types and then
finally we want to import our stylesheet
that we want to use and we're going to
use our links function to inject it
inside our HTML so now let's add these
changes in our app we are already
importing our links so in the top let's
import our links function types now
let's import our stylesheet that's found
in the app under app.css file this is
where you could find all the styles used
in this application and finally let's
use our links function to import our
Styles now let's refresh your
application beautiful and now you could
see our stylesheet is being applied now
that our application taken shape we
probably want to navigate to other pages
so let's give it a try let's click on
your name oh my gosh it is throwing a
404 but notice that we're going to a URL
contacts1 so inside our application if
you scroll down we see our anchor tags
when we click on the anchor tag it
changes our URL to contacts SL1 the
reason why it's not found is because we
don't have any routes that represent
that so let's go ahead inside our app
folder create a new folder called routes
and inside our routes let's create a new
file and we're going to call it
contacts. TSX and now let's create a
very basic component here and I'm going
to call it contact route and now let's
go back to our application and notice
when I go to/ contacts I don't see
anything well the reason that we don't
see anything is because we don't have a
way to tell remix hey go ahead and show
that route so the way you would fix this
is by using Outlet so in order to make
this work we're going to go ahead and
import outlet from
remix then we're going to use our Outlet
by creating a div where we're going to
pass all of our children
routes so now let's make these changes
in the code and see if we could see our
newly generated route So within our
root. TSX file let's go ahead and import
our
outlet and finally let's scroll to the
bottom and after the sidebar div we're
going to add another div with ID of
detail and inside here we're going to
add our Outlet let's refresh our
application and noris you're now able to
see our contact route we are making some
excellent progress why don't you go make
yourself some cup of coffee take a
little break or tea or water whatever it
is you like to drink and then when
you're back we going to take a look at
how to create Dynamic routes and use the
link component to navigate see you in a
bit all right let's jump back into it
currently in our application we have two
anchor tags which are our links so when
we look at our application we have your
name your friend these are the links
that we just saw in code when I click
them we still fail because we don't have
a route that matches the URL route that
we're looking to get so to fix this in
our code we're going to create two
addition routes so here I'm going to
create a new file called
contacts. one we'll use number one. TSX
and then we're going to create another
one new file called
contacts. 2. TSX so looking at our link
we are navigating to contact SL1 contact
SL2 and that's exactly what we did here
we Define our routes whenever you use
the dot separator the routes that
basically means contact SL one so that's
what you want to go and let's go ahead
add some basic jsx here so we could see
it here so I'm going to say contact one
route and then I'm going to copy this
same example I'm going to go here and
I'm going to say contact 2 route so now
when we go back into our example and we
click your name we get contact route
contact two route it doesn't fail
anymore but notice that we only see the
contact route here and so the way we
could fix this is two ways we could
either remove it and then we'll either
match contact one contact two or we
could use this as a layout route and to
make this a layout route I'm just going
to say
layout contact route and in order for us
to render the items from our children
routes we would need to use an outlet
and let's put this under
H1 just like
so so now when we go back Norris we have
our layout route and then we see both
our your name contact one and your
friend contact two so Norris when we are
matching contacts and one we are
matching the contacts that's why we're
able to render this layout and then
we're also matching one and that's why
we would see contact one route inside
there now for instance if you did not
want to have a layout route you could
just remove this and this is what we
going to do for now so now when we go to
your name we're just going to see just
those routes for contact one and contact
2 but the issue is that this could be
contact one this could be contact 32
this could be 57 and so the idea is like
we don't want to continue to make routes
from 1 to 50 or 70 however many items we
might have so this case we want to use a
dynamic route and the way we create a
dynamic route is that we instead of
passing a one we could signify a dynamic
parameter by using dollar sign and we
going to say contact ID and now when we
do this we could remove this one and
delete and I'm going to refactor this to
say contact Dynamic route just so we
could clearly know what route we're in
and I'm going to say contact Dynamic
route and so now when we go back to our
application regardless if you go to your
name your friend they're both going to
render now that we know how Dynamic
routes work and remix let's go ahead and
set up our contacts ID TSX file by
importing this existing code now if
you're following via this documentation
you could paste it from here but I'm
also going to create these gist just
with the code Snippets that you need and
I'll make sure to have them in the link
in the description below so make sure
you copy the code and let's inside vs
code in our contact id. TSX file and now
let's go ahead and paste that Boiler
code here and we'll go through it in a
little bit but first let's check it out
and see if it worked so now if we
refresh our appc application norise for
our Dynamic route we now see this boiler
plate that we will update as necessary
but before we could update it we need to
learn how to load data so let's first
review how you can use a loader function
to add data to your remix application
that you could get from either external
API or from making a direct call to your
database or in our case in this example
application our dummy data in remix we
have a load function that allows you to
load your data so let's take a look at a
basic implementation before we continue
with this tutorial we can access a
loader function by exporting it in our
application so for instance here we're
going to export a sync function call it
loader and inside the return we could
return the data that we want and right
now we are returning this dami data but
this loader function runs on the server
and we could make an API call or call to
the database to retrieve the data that
we need once we declare our loader
function next we're going to import our
use loader data hook that allows us to
get our data from the loader so notice
how we are using use loader data hook
and saving it to a data variable which
will have our data so let's see how this
is going to look in our code so inside
our root. DSX file we're going to first
import use loader data from remix then
we're going to Define our basic loader
function and in order for us to get that
data we are going to use our use loader
data hook and we're going to give it a
type of loader so typescript doesn't
complain and now let's go ahead and
console.log our data and nor we get our
data that we are passing from our loader
function so now let's see how we could
load all of our users to populate our
left sidebar here so inside our root.
TSX file first we're going to import get
contacts from that data this is
available in your application if you go
inside that data and you search for g
contacts you're going to see this
function and what it's doing it's
getting our data to populate our users
and currently this data is stored in our
app application but as we continue we'll
show you how to get this data from our
strappy API so now inside our loader
function let's go ahead and use our get
contact function so we're going to say
const contacts and we're going to await
our get contacts and we're going to go
ahead and return now whenever you're
returning items from the loader function
it actually returns as a response so
remix has a helpful function for us that
allows us to return this response with
all the appropriate headers within so
that's what we're going to do we're
going to say return contacts now when we
take a look at our console log notice we
get an array of all of our users so now
let's update our return code to allow us
to visualize the data that we just
received you could find the code snippet
inside the remix tutorial here and we're
going to copy the contact next H code
snippet here and we're going to paste
inside of our application now if you're
not following this tutorial which you
should use it as reference I'm also
going to have these gists that I'm going
to put in the description below as well
just so you could find the code Snippets
if for some reason you can't find them
so inside my application I am going to
scroll down to our navigation here and
I'm going to replace the code within the
UL and I'm going to paste it in
and we just have to rename our use load
of data that we're getting here instead
of data we're going to call it contacts
and we could remove this console log and
now when we navigate back to our
application notice we have all of the
items coming from our fake database
which is pretty awesome so let's do a
quick recap before we move on so to
recap we imported our loader function
that allows us to call a method that
either connects to our database or makes
an API request to get our data then we
return our data using the Json method
which allows us to return it as a
response with all the appropriate
headers you could learn more about it on
the remix documentation but it is being
imported from at remix dasr note package
once we get that data back we're using
the use loader data hook to save that
data into contacts and then we iterating
through those contacts mapping through
them and rendering our links and this is
what we see here so next we're going to
take a look how we could click on any
one of these individual links and notice
as we click them the URL changes so in
order to be able to display the items
here in our Details page which we're
going to create too we need to figure
out how we could access the URL prams to
allows to do that and that's exactly
what we're going to do in the next
section so from our root. TSX file let's
go ahead and copy our loader function
inside our contact id. TSX file which is
our Dynamic route after line five let's
go ahead and import our loader now if we
take a look inside our data. file you're
going to see that we have get contact
method that expects an ID which is a
string which will return one item for
based on the ID that we pass so inside
our context. id. TSX let's first go
ahead and import our our get contact
from data now let's refactor this to
reflect that we're only getting one item
now it's complaining that we did not
import our Json method so let's go ahead
and import it from remix and now we need
to provide an ID so you're wondering
where do we find the ID so the ID is
based on this Dynamic attribute that we
have so in the loader we have access to
the params and typescript is going to
complain because we need to import the
pramps and you could import them from
remix so we say we need type of loader
function arcs and let's make sure that
we add it here perfect so now typescript
is not complaining and finally if we
take a look at our params I'm just going
to console log for now notice that we
have an object and the key and the key
is contact ID and then it has the name
name of the item that we are searching
for and if you're wondering where that
name was defined it was defined here so
anytime in our application when our URL
pams change notice how they're changing
here for instance I'm going to go to me
Paul Browski right here if we take a
look in our code notice the Pam that we
get is Paul broslovski so now I'm able
to access that so we're going to go
ahead and here just going to do const
contact ID equals param and we're
pulling that contact ID and we're going
to pass that contact ID to our method to
get our data now right now it's
complaining what if contact ID is not
defined so we probably should do a check
to see if it exists first you could find
this package on npm and read more about
what it does but it makes it an easy way
for us to check if an item is falsy or
not and if so it will throw an error so
let's go ahead copy the install script
in my terminal I'm going to paste the
script in and install once the script
installed I'm going to restart my
project by running yarn Dev and now we
could add a check to see if the params
exist so we're going to use the
invariant method we're going to pass the
pam. contact ID if it doesn't exist
we're going to return an error message
and if so we're going to continue and
notice how the error goes away whenever
we return our contact Maybe we don't
have any contacts so we should do a
check so we're going to do if no contact
found let's throw a new response with
not found and return 404 some people
like to do the if statement with the
brackets but for me it just makes my
brain feel much easier when I remove the
brackets for on liners and in my mind
it's just easier to read should you do
this I don't know but this is what I'm
going to do here and now that we are
getting our contacts we're going to
import our use loader data and inside
our component we're going to go ahead
and say cons contact equals use loader
data type of data loader and we're going
to remove this dummy text that we have
here so now let's do a quick recap we
are using our loader we calling our get
contact method where we passing our ID
that comes from our params if we don't
have a contact we're going to throw a
not found and if we do have a contact
we're going to return it here inside our
contact that we're going to pass to our
code below so now let's navigate to a
browser and see if it worked great look
at this this works we are able to get
all of our data coming from our phony
data API so in the next video before
continuing with this tutorial let's
actually go ahead and set up strappy to
show us how we could get data from an
actual API endpoint this way you're
going to have your front end with remix
and you're going to have strappy as your
back end so before we install strappy go
ahead and grab another cup of coffee or
tea or whatever you like to consume take
a little breather take a little break
think about all the things that we've
done and then come back and we'll be
ready to set up strappy to set up our
API and you'll see it's going to go so
quick because strappy allows you to
create your API in minutes and I'm
really really excited to show you how to
do that all right and welcome back today
we're going to take a look on how to set
up strappy strappy allows you to create
an API in minutes but what's awesome
it's easy to get started but also if you
need additional customization if you
want to dive deep add additional
functionality add extra middleware
controllers policies you are able to do
that but what's awesome for beginners
you could get started with it right as
it is to create an amazing backend for
your project that's going to have this
amazing admin area so just like we've
been using our remix documentation
strappy has amazing documentation as
well so you could always reference it
when you get stuck but we're going to
jump right into it so it's very easy to
get started we going to use the npx
create strappy app at latest to get our
project going so inside my terminal
currently I'm in My remix folder so I'm
going to move one level down into the
root of my project and notice how we
have our My remix app so now I'm going
to use npx create strappy at app at
latest and we're going to call it my
strappy app just to stay consistent with
our naming are they good names I don't
know and you could choose quick start
but I'm not going to do it just to show
you some of the options that you'll see
so this is going to ask do you want to
get started yes sure yes let's download
the following packages and install them
once the process is all set you have the
quick start option but you also have the
custom options so let's take a look
custom options allow you to choose if
you want to use JavaScript or typescript
in that case we're going to stick with
JavaScript for the moment and here you
have your options of different databases
you could use sqlite postgress or MySQL
I'm going to stick with sqlite yes that
sounds good for the database uh that
where to save the files locally and it's
going to go ahead and create our strappy
application now that our application has
installed I'm going to to CD into my
strappy project and I'm going to run
yarn develop so because this is our
first time starting our strappy
application we have to create our first
admin user so I'm going to do Paul Bratz
from coding after
30@gmail.com
let's do password monkey1 234 since this
is running locally that sounds secure
enough no one's going to guess monkey
123 forever let's click Start and now we
we set up our strappy application and
the dashboard so let's do a quick tour
on content manager this is where you're
going to see all your content types and
collection types that you have created
currently we have just the user
collection type that has no users yet
and if we take a look at the content
type Builder this is where you actually
are able to create new collection types
content types which we'll learn more as
we continue through this tutorial you
could see that our user collection type
here's some of the fields that it has
username text email and so on and we
will create a new collection shortly but
first let's just finish up this quick
little exploration of strappy admin area
here we have our media library all your
files that are stored in strappy will
show up here afterwards we have our
plugins if you have any additional
plugins installed you're going to see
them here and an example of a plugin for
instance if you wanted to extend
function on strappy and store your files
in Cloud andary you could install
strappy cloud andary plugin that allows
you to do that and if you're trying to
figure out where where to find these
awesome plugins you could always check
out the marketplace and if I say search
for cloudinary and it's going to be a
provider and here you could see the
cloud provider and if you want to
install you could copy the command and
install it and then we going to take a
look under settings we have our general
overview all the details about our
application a couple of different
options the the ones that we're going to
use most this tutorial is under rolls
under rolls you are able to Define which
endpoints have permissions and you could
either say they're publicly meaning
there's no authentication required or
you could make them authenticated and
this is something we'll dive into deeper
with that being said let's go ahead and
create our first collection type so in
our current application if we go into
Apps and we take a look at our data.
file we're going to see our types for
our contacts so we know that we need to
have an ID a first name which is a
string last name is a string we have an
avatar which is a string which
represents the URL for where we going to
store the image then we have Twitter and
notes and favorites is a Boolean so what
we could do is we could actually create
our strappy collection type for our
users So within strappy application
let's navigate to content type Builder
and we're going to create a new
collection if you have like many users
many products you would create a
collection type if you have let's say a
single item like a settings page or what
have you you could use create new single
types but we're going to start here
click create new collection type and
we're going to call it contact and click
continue and now you'll see all these
different fields that you have available
to structure your data for instance you
have your text which is a string you
have your Boolean you have your
different editors available to you we
have your Json data you could represent
emails passwords numbers dates media
enums UI ID different relationships and
we have a markdown text editor as well
as you could create components and
Dynamics notes which we will talk uh
much later when we work on our
Cornerstone project after we are done
with this remixes traion introduction so
for this we're going to use text and for
our first name we're going to say first
and let's click another do another text
field it's going to be last for the last
name add another field let's take a look
at what we have here so we did first we
did last we have Avatar which is going
to be for our image URL so let's do text
say Avatar add another field uh we need
Twitter let's copy Twitter um text also
going to be for the Twitter feed and
then we have notes so we're going to do
text we're going to call it note I think
it's notes or notes we have notes okay
let's say we call it notes and it's
going to be long text and let's see do
we need anything else and yes we do so
add another field and we going to have a
bullion to signify that this is
something that we favored it and I think
that is all we need so check this out
we're going to click finish click save
and now when we take a look at our
content manager we now see our newly
created collection type contact so if I
click on it create a new entry I'm able
to add my information I'm going to say
Paul Bratz I have a URL here for my
image and I'm going to go ahead and say
hello from strappy and we'll say true
for our Boolean click save and publish
so now if we want to give permission to
users to be able to get this data we are
going to go into settings under roles
and we're going to say it's publicly
available and now you're going to see
all the different available API
endpoints that we have and this is our
newly created contact endpoint so if I
click on it we're able to give
permission for create delete find find
one and update so we're going to go for
both find and find one and click save
and noise now that if we navigate to our
strappy application endpoint / API
contacts because we gave the permission
we are going to see our API response so
we literally created our back end and we
now have a working endpoint that allows
us to get our data so now let's see how
we could get this data inside our remix
application inside our data. s file
we're going to make all the changes by
the way in remix you could Define if
your files run on the server or on the
client for our data fetching file we
want it to all run on the server so I
could be specific by renaming this file
data. server. TS and this is going to go
ahead and it's going to run all this
code server side which is awesome so now
within our data. server. TS file let's
refactor it a little bit we're going to
delete this top part we're going to keep
the type definition here for now and
then let's scroll down to get contacts
and let's delete everything from get
contacts to the export type Here and Now
within all of these functions that are
getting that fake data we're actually
going to delete all the code inside and
just leave them as placement functions
to make our changes to reflect getting
data from strappy and I'm going to do it
for update context as well
and we're going to do it for delete as
well and this array here we're going to
save to our variable which we'll use
later as reference and if you scroll all
the way down to the end you're going to
see that we have this dot for each we
don't need it just remove it nice now
that we have refactored our data. serts
file we could start implementing our new
code So within get contacts function
we're going to go ahead and create a try
catch block and if there's an error
we're just going to cons log that error
nice and within the tri block we're
going to do cons three response and it's
going to equal to await and we're going
to use fetch once we fetch the data we
going to get the Json so you're going to
do data equals await
response. Json and inside our fetch
we're going to pass our strappy app URL
and to that we're going to pend our
endpoint which is going to be API SL
contacts to get our data now let's add
our URL variable basically I'll check do
we have a strap URL andv parameter if we
do use that if not default to Local Host
which is perfectly fine and when we get
this data from strappy if you look at
the structure we have data ID attributes
and so on but what I want to do is I
want to flatten this response so we have
the data object and instead of
attributes we just have the attributes
and this is helpful that if we were
getting nested data it would also have
data attribute data attribute and so on
and so by flattening it it makes a
little bit much more easier to use an
our response I also like this idea of
having an intermediary function that
allows us to define the structure of our
return so that way when we make changes
in our API instead of having to redo our
whole frontend we could just rewrite our
transform function and I already have
this flatten attribute function that I
wrote that I'm going to share either in
this gist or in a accompanying uh blog
post which you could use when doing this
tutorial as well as the final project
and let's go ahead and paste this
function above our URL here and we're
going to minimize it so it doesn't act
like a big eyesore and now here we going
to do another variable called const Flat
attributes data and that that's going to
come from our flatten attributes
function that we imported and it's going
to get our data and this data object is
going to have our data and our meta
information so we just want the data and
finally we're going to return our
flattened attributes data response now
because we updated this file to be
called data. server. TS we need to
navigate to root. TSX and make sure that
we make that change we also did the same
thing inside our contact ID TSX file so
make sure that we rename the Imports
accordingly so server and same thing do
server so now let's see if we're able to
get our strappy data I'm going to
restart my strappy application by
running yarn develop once your strappy
instance is running go ahead and restart
your remix app by running yarn Dev great
now we're getting our data and where is
this data coming from it's coming from
our strappy application so check this
out if I go to my strappy instance under
contacts I click Paul and I'm going to
change to my full last name and we're
going to take the starway by setting
this to false click save and when we go
back to our application and refresh
notice we have our changes so next let's
fix us being able to get our single
entry because right now if we click Paul
rowski we get not found because
currently we brought our application
because instead of getting our dummy
data we are now looking to pull data
from strappy so let's go into the code
and fix this first but first inside our
strappy application let's go under
settings roles public and click on
contact whenever we found all of our
items we use the find endpoint and
that's found by going to API SL contact
whenever we pass a parameter like one
the ID of our contact it's going to look
for that single entry and notice that
instead of returning a array it returns
an object so that's the endpoint we're
going to look to use so if we could take
a look here we need to go to API context
and provide the ID so let's click save
and within our code editor and navigate
to data. server. TS file our endpoint
code is going to be similar to this code
that we have here so I'm going to copy
it let's go to the get cont Texs by ID
here I'm going to open this code block
and I'm going to paste in our code and I
must have missed the closing bracket
there so let's go and add that we are
going to be making a request to contact
and the only difference is we now have
to append our ID which we're going to
get from this parameter everything else
should be the same so now let's go ahead
and navigate to our single uh contact ID
page here and we we're still getting our
params using our param attribute in our
loader function and we're passing that
ID to get contact so that should have
been an easy fix we should now see the
data now let's see if it worked so back
in our app which originally was throwing
a 404 let's refresh and notice now we
are able to get our data so now before
handling edit delete or start our user
we want to have the ability to add the
users so let's connect the behavior to
our new button if we currently click our
new button we get 405 method not allowed
that's because we're going to use
strappy to allow us create users and
save them to our database so let's get
started inside our code inside the app
folder under root navigate to the submit
button here instead of using a button
here we're just going to have a link to
a new form that we're going to create so
we're going to say link to and we're
going to link to contacts SLC create and
we're going to say create currently this
route doesn't exist so let's go ahead
and make it inside our routes folder
let's create a new file and we're going
to call it
contacts. create. TSX we're going to
create a very simple placeholder
component and we going to call it create
route we could remove this react import
since we're not using it and now that we
have this place holder route we could
test it so let's go back so in our
application if I click new now we'll fix
the styling in a little bit but let's
check it out if we click create Norris
now it takes us to a create route so
let's add a class to our link here we're
going to say class name equals button
link and we're going to navigate to our
app.css file found inside the app folder
and we're going to copy some of these
styl Lings for our new button link class
so I'm going to say button link and
we're going to copy all of this button
code as well as this color and font
weight now that we have our new button
link class this should apply these
changes to our new link component so
notice that our create button looks
pretty good it's almost done the last
thing we need to do is remove the
styling and under font weight let's do
text decoration and it will be none and
no our button now looks normal and when
whenever we click create again it takes
us to our create page so in our project
let's navigate to our routes contact.
create. TSX file here's where we had our
placeholder text what we're going to do
now just to make it easier for ourselves
we're going to paste a snippet all the
Snippets I will make sure to link in the
description of the video to All the
gists that I'm using and in this case it
is a remix create form starter I'm going
to click raw do contrl a copy all to
select select all the code and contrl +
C to copy and then let's navigate back
to our code editor and paste it in all
this does is paste our basic boiler
plate that we need for this form I
created a form input component and
basically is just a flexible component
to allow us to quickly Define our input
elements but the part that you want to
focus on is the our input is using the
name attribute that's very important if
you notice we don't have any use state
or use effect or any react ways to
create a controlled form where we passed
a unchange so you're wondering where
well how are we getting our form data
well we're using standard web form API
so whenever you submit a form it's going
to pass the values in the URL so we'll
have the name plus the value that we
have in the form so let me just show you
what I mean before implementing the Code
remix handles form submission similar
the way it is done traditionally using
the form tag this may be unfamiliar to
some newer developers but HML form
causes navigation similar to link the
only difference is that you have the
ability to change the request method get
via or post so let's take a look at what
this means here's a simple form example
and this is using the classical way of
just submitting the form and the action
refers to an endpoint which is going to
do something with the data in this case
they're using get the form data can be
sent either as a URL variable when using
method get or as a HTTP post transaction
when using method post when using the
get request and this is the example
we're going to take a look at the form
data will be appended to the URL if we
were to make a post request that form
data would be appended to the body of
the HTTP request so if we take a look at
this example when I put Paul Bratz and
click submit notice that in the URL our
form data is being passed inside our
code if I do action equals test and
Method equals get let's try submitting
our form so within our application we're
going to do Paul Bratz and click create
since this test standpoint does doesn't
exist we see four or four not found but
you could see that we have our first
name Paul and last name Bratz remix has
a form component that basically does the
same thing the only difference is except
of sending the request to the server it
uses the client side routing and sends
it to the routes action function which
we're going to talk about in a little
bit so let's take a look at this quick
remix example whenever you want to
create delete or update data on your
website we will be making a post request
so we have our basic form already set up
so the next thing we need to do is
create an action in this case they're
defining an action in a separate file
but we're actually going to Define our
action inside the same file that we're
working so in order to create a function
we just need to export a sync function
called action so let's go ahead and do
that inside my code I'm going to type
export uh sync function and it's going
to be called action and we have the
request available to us and we do need
to import action function arcs type so
let's go ahead and do that we're going
to say request and let's import type
action function arcs now we're able to
access our form data from our request
object so we're going to say await
request. form data there's multiple ways
to get the data but we're going to use
the simplest one we're going to say cons
data equals and we're going to use
object. from entries and we're going to
pass in our form data and all we're
going to do is just return our data in
order to see the response from our
action we need to use a hook and the
hook is called use action data so under
navigate I could do const form data
equals use action data and let's con log
it so currently it's going to be
undefined because we don't have any
submissions to our form so let's import
form and here we're going to replace the
HTML element with the remix form method
is going to be post and we're not going
to Define an action whenever you don't
Define an action wherever the form is
submitted it's going to go ahead and
look for the nearest declared action
that we have in the same file so now
let's give this a test so my application
I'm going to say Paul Bratz at Twitter
HTTP some image. JPEG and hey so now
that we click create we don't visually
see anything here but let's check out
our conso log notice that we have the
output for our data first name Paul last
name Brad Twitter Avatar and our note
and that's all coming from our form and
so the recap quickly before we continue
whenever submitting forms and remix
we're literally using the traditional
method of submitting forms we Define
what type of request we want in this
case is post when we're using the post
request as we learned the data will be
appended to our body of the htttp
request and we have access to it in our
request so in remix when we were
submitting the form we were able to get
the data using the form data method on
the request and save it so now that
we're able to get our form data to our
action we will be able to make an API
call to save the data to DB using
strappy and that's exactly what we're
going to do next so taking a look at a
strappy application if you go to
settings under roles take a look under
public permissions we're going to look
at contacts and we're going to enable
create and basically in order to post
data to strappy we just need to make a
post request to this API endpoint so
let's save to enable our ability to
create posts and before we add the code
let's check the strappy docs you could
navigate to strappy website click get
started and it's going to take you to
the docs we're going to scroll down to
apis and click on rest API introduction
and here you can get more information on
how all the different endpoints work for
instance if you want to make a get
request post request to create an item
that's what we're going to look at now
how to make get requests put requests
and delete so let's create create entry
here it's going to take us to an example
to take a look what we need to do and
basically we need to make a post request
to the endp that we specified in our
case is going to be API contacts and
noise how we need to wrap it in data
object and pass our attributes inside
there and that's exactly what we're
going to do and when the data is
submitted correctly you are going to get
a response that we could check if we
successfully submitted the form or
return some errors that we're going to
take a look in a little bit so now let's
go back into our code and let's navigate
to our data. server. TS file and the
good news we're going to follow very
similar pattern here so I'm going to go
to the get cont conts and I'm going to
copy this whole try and catch block
because it's going to be very similar
and we're going to navigate to uh create
empty contact and this is actually going
to be renamed to create contact because
we're not going to create an empty
contact we're going to create actual
contact and so what we're going to pass
inside here is our data and our data is
going to be any right now we'll come
back and add typing later uh but for now
let's just get stuff to work and it's
going to be a post request to our API
cont contact so if you don't pass any
second parameters on fetch it will
automatically make a get request but we
want to make a post request so we going
to add an additional object where we
going to pass the information that we
need so we're going to say method is
going to be post then we have to Define
headers it's going to be an object so
now let's define the content type I
can't speak and type at the same time
it's okay and it's going to be
application Json and finally the last
thing we need to do is pass our body and
we're going to wrap our data within a
data object just like we saw in the docs
and we're going to D structure our data
that we're passing into our form and
then the most important thing we need to
wrap this in json. stringify to
stringify our data being sent and then
this is complaining here no big deal
we're going to change it to response
data and then we going to change this to
response data perfect and then
everything else should be all set so
basically what we're going to do we're
going to make a post request to our API
conts endpoint to allow us to send data
that we get from our form to make a new
entry so now let's go ahead and add it
to our contact create form so we're
going to remove our con log here and
we're going to say const new entry is
going to await create contact and into
our create contact we're going to pass
our data object and now let's import
create contact import create contact
from our data. server.js file and
finally we're going to just return new
entry and we're going to cons selct the
response after our data is created and
currently right now there's a couple of
things we do need to add for instance we
should probably have form validation
which we'll do next and probably if
there's a successful entry creation we
should probably redirect but for now
we're just going to test that it works
to see that we're posting data to our
strappy endpoint and just make sure that
we're able to get the conso logged in
the response so let's go ahead to our
front end application we're going to
navigate to our create form I'm going to
say test test test and that's fine for
now we'll leave the other one blank it's
no big deal right now we click create so
noris it posted our data uh because we
were able to create it and let's just
check inside our strappy instance
navigate to content manager to contacts
and notice that we are able to post and
what I hope that you really appreciate
it is the fact that when we added a new
item without doing anything remix was
smart enough to be able to automatically
refresh your sidebar we didn't have to
store anything in context or state it
just smart enough to do it so if we
create a new entry let's say test two we
say create boom it's right there so
notice that we're able to get our data
and so norce we didn't pass a image
maybe we should check that passing image
is required so we run into erors like
this so next we're going to take a look
on form validation to improve our create
form form all right we're making amazing
progress so next let's add some form
validation to our form and to to do this
we're going to simplify the process by
using Zod Zod is a library that allows
you to add form validation very very
easily or object validation so we're
going to go ahead and first install it
so I'm going to click on copy and paste
the command in my terminal inside our
remix app we're going to run the command
and install it then let's restart our
application by running yarn Dev next
inside our application let's go ahead
and import Zod fantastic and now we able
to use it so let's navigate to Zod
homepage from our npm and let me make
this bigger and then we're going to get
to uh basic usage here and here just
shows you kind of like the basic uh
thing that we're going to do here we
import side and then we're going to
create a basic uh schema that's going to
Define our structure for our form data
and here we could take a look all the
different checks we could do we could
check if it's a string if it's a number
if it's a big end if it's undefined and
so on and you could read more about it
on there but right now let's just jump
in into our example and get started so
one side is important here inside a form
and right after our data we're going to
create const and we're going to say form
schema where we're going to define the
structure of our schema it's going to
equal to using Zod object and we're
going to pass in an object and here
we're going to Define all the things
that we want to check so let's scroll
down our form has a first name last name
Twitter and Avatar and notes so we're
going to write very basic checks here so
we're going to say Avatar it needs to be
a string it needs to be a URL and
minimum of two characters so it can't be
blank then we're going to check our
first name and we're going to say again
it has to be a string and again we're
just going to say minimum of two but you
could add whatever values make sense for
your application and we're going to do
the same thing for our last name last
and don't forget your comments everyone
and then finally we're going to add
Twitter and again it's going to be Z
string and minimum of two and again I'm
doing very basic checks here just to
kind of show you how Zod works but you
could decide and look more into it to
kind of see how you could create custom
checks for your items and notes we're
going to leave out because it's going to
be optional we're not going to worry too
much about it right now so now that we
have our form schema let's create a a
new variable called validated fields and
it's going to be equal to form
schema. saave pars and inside here we're
going to add the items that we want to
check so we want to check our Avatar and
then we basically specify where that's
coming from and we're getting our avatar
from our form data here so we're going
to say data. Avatar next we want to
check our first name data. first we're
going to do the same thing for last last
equals data. last and finally we're
going to check Twitter and it's going to
be data. Twitter fantastic now we could
check for our validated Fields so we
going to do an if statement and we're
going to say if validated fields. not
successful we're going to return our
error so we're going to say return and
we're going to use our adjacent object
here if we have errors we're going to
get them from validated fields. error
and we're going to flatten the response
just to make it more consumable and all
we want to get is field errors then
we're also going to return a message and
we going to do keep this message generic
which is going to say please fill out
all missing fields and for data we're
going to return null because we weren't
able to successfully submit the form and
then make sure you import Json at the
top here and that's coming from remix
run node and we're just going to update
this so we could have one line here so
I'm just going to say type here instead
otherwise it would have had to do it in
two lines perfect now that our form is
all set we should be able to see our
errors coming back when we make a
mistake so let's uh going to do here
data from action just so we could see it
and so now let's try to submit our form
without passing any of our programs and
this should be cut by our Zod validator
and because we're not going to pass all
the items it should return an error it
should return a message that we have
here and also all the fields where the
error has occurred which we'll be able
to visually show in our input in just a
minute but first let's just check it out
so inside our application I'm going to
open my inspector here go to console log
and we're going to go to create and I'm
not going to fill anything out I'm just
going to click create so Norris when we
click create we now get all of our
validation and again this is all
happening on the server because actions
and loaders run on the server which is
pretty cool and when we fail our
validation it's going to show us hey
here's the places where the errors have
occurred and it's going to give us the
message errors that we want to show to
our users and so now that we know that
we're getting our errors let's show
these errors to our users in our form
and so if you navigate norise how we
have an error uh prop that we could pass
so now instead of false let's do form
data and we're going to check if it's
undefined or doesn't have errors just
return false and we're going to say
errors and this is probably complaining
so let's go here and under use action
data let's do type of action and this
should stop our complaint and no boom we
fixed it so now let's go ahead and add
this to the rest of the form inputs and
I'll show you what is doing inside the
input component in just a second that we
have here but once we have all the
validation we could go ahead and scroll
down now so let's take a look at our
form input so Norris we are getting the
errors prop and what we're doing is we
are iterating through the errors and if
the error matches the field name we
return the message so let's take a look
and see if this works so now when I try
to submit the form by clicking create
notice that we have all the basic errors
showing up to us and so we want to make
sure that we fix the error and if I fix
one and click create noise the eror goes
away but I still have all the other ones
so let's go Bratz at Twitter let's find
a nice pixel image pexels.com this looks
great copy image address let's go back
to our application let's throw in that
URL and say hey there and now we're
going to create submit and notice that
it went ahead and created our form and
right now the experience is still kind
of terrible because although we created
our form the form didn't clear we didn't
navigate to the item that we created so
wouldn't be nice after the thing that's
created it navigates to that thing so
let's see how to do that next in the
next part of this video so looking in
the remix docks we going to look for
redirect and click enter and here we
have an example redirecting from form
action and it's going to give us some
examples but basically we want to use
redirect and we want to import redirect
from remix run node and basically once
we have the user ID we can redirect to
that newly created item so let's go
ahead and Implement that in our code so
let's import redirect after Json here
and we're going to use it right after
our new entry and for now we just going
to return our redirect and we're going
to pass where do you want to redirect it
to and and we're going to redirect it to
contacts slash and we're going to append
new entry. ID so whenever we create a
new entry we have an ID and we going to
redirect our form to that new screen so
let's go ahead and check if it works so
let's give it a try we're going to say
new test at Twitter and we're going to
paste the URL of an image and say hello
and now when we create the new item it
should redirect us which you did and
boom that is a great experience nice we
making progress through learning remix
Basics with strappy which is pretty cool
so now it'd be really awesome if we
could now select an entry click the edit
button and be able to update our entry
so that's exactly what we're going to do
next to get started we're going to use a
code snippet from remix tutorial here in
their documentation and so the next
route we're going to create it's to be
able to add a form where we able to
update our items so I'm going to copy
contacts. Conta id. edit. TSX and that's
going to be a route we're going to
create and typically the reason why
we're doing a dash afterwards if you
look here at the note by default in
remix if a route matches with the same
prefix name it will be considered as a
child route and be nest inside the
parent we don't want to do that and the
way you prevent that behavior is adding
the dash and that's exactly what we're
doing here and so now let's go in our
code inside our app inside our routes
we're going to create a new file and
we're going to add our route endpoint so
whenever we navigate to contact slash an
ID of our item sledit it's going to
bring us to this page so let's add the
code snippet I'm going to scroll down
and I'm going to click here on copy and
inside our code editor let's paste it in
just remember we did update the tutorial
instead of using dummy data that we had
but actually using our strappy API so
we're getting our contacts from our
strappy endpoint where we did update the
data file to be data. server file and
get contacts is found on that file it's
just a quick refresher if we go to data.
server we see that we have our get
contacts and create contact and get
contact functions that get the data so
now that our memory is refreshed let's
go back so we won't need to change too
much except just to point to our
function that we refactor to use strappy
and the last update I'm going to do here
I like to have this throw on one line
just because it mentally makes my brain
happy and if you scroll down when we use
this loader to get our strappy data we
get the data through this contacts using
used loader data and we are setting it
as the initial value using the default
value prop so we're getting contact
object and we have items there for the
first name the last name our Twitter
handle our Avatar URL as well as our
notes at contact notes so now everything
should work in terms of showing our data
so back in our application now if I hit
edit norise it takes us to our contact
slid sledit page with all of our data
already PR filled and we don't see a
Twitter handle here let me just check
that's because I didn't add a Twitter
handle here let's try another entry here
we go let's click edit so notice again
our form is pre-filled and we're able to
now make our updates so to make our
updates we're going to do something
similar to when we created the form so
all we have to do is connect that logic
to the save button so inside our edit.
TSX file we're going to scroll to the
bottom and we're going to find our
submit button because our submit button
has type of submit we don't really have
to do anything because whenever you
click a button which has a type of
submit it's automatically going to fire
the form action so all we have to do is
we have to Define our our action
function and our action function is
going to expect a post request to handle
updating our contact so we're going to
do export const action equals a sync and
inside this function we're going to pass
our params and our request and this is
coming from
action function arcs and we're going to
do our error function I realized that in
other examples I was not using error
function I prefer not using error
functions uh but I just want to show you
that this works as well and let's import
our action function Arc types so let's
do here action function arcs and we're
going to check with the invariant
function like we did in our loader to
see that our contact ID is exists from
our params next we need to get our form
data and that's coming from our
request. form data and if you're just
trying to remember how we get this data
it is passed automatically to us from
our forms using the name uh attribute so
we're going to get name first name last
we're going to get our name Twitter and
that's all going to be in our form data
object that we get from our form so
we're going to D structure our data from
our form using
object. from entries and we're going to
pass our form data so before we get too
far let's
console.log our data and let's return
null for now so it doesn't complain that
we don't have a return in our form
action and I'm just going to go ahead
and restart my project yarn develop to
start my strappy application and in the
front end of our application we're going
to do yarn
Dev so back in our project we're going
to go to any entry we're going to click
edit and it takes us to a form so I'm
just going to see if we're getting this
data passed to our action can we see
this in the action and let's click save
when we click save nothing happens but
let's look at our console log here and
notice how we're getting our console log
that says can we see this in the action
so I know that it's working we know that
it's updating our form data so now that
we know we're getting our data in our
action let's go ahead and write a
function to handle our update so I'm
going to do const update response equals
await and we're going to call this
update contact by ID and this is going
to get our data and we're going to do a
very basic check here if
update. response error we're going going
to return Json object and inside here
we're going to say data equals null
we're going to say error equals update
response. error and then if nothing
terrible happens we going to redirect to
contacts slash and we're going to pass
our params contact ID nice so we could
do additional error handling here but
for now we're just going to keep it
super simple and if we wanted to get
this response here just remember we
would use our use action data so we
could do const form response and it's
going to use action data and it's going
to be type of action and for now we're
just going to
console.log
form response then we going to say from
action
and so anytime this if statement gets
triggered it's going to return data null
and our error that will'll be able to
see in the front end and we could show
that error to our user but we'll come
back to this let's just make sure that
we could actually update our data on our
back end so I'm going to now go to our
data. server file so we're going to
update our update contacts we're going
to rename it to be update contact by ID
and here instead of updates uh we keep
it updates that makes uh perfect sense
and this is actually going to be very
similar to our create method so let's go
here and I'm just going to copy this
whole try and catch block here and we're
going to paste it in and the only
difference is going to be we're making a
call to API contacts slash and we're
going to be passing our ID and then
instead of post we're going to be making
a put request
and we are going to rename this to
updates because that's what we want to
be passing and then finally once we get
the response we going to return the
response if not it's going to throw an
error here and if something goes wrong
the cat black will conso Lo the error so
if you're wondering how do I know that
we need to make a request to API
contacts while passing the ID so let's
take a look in our strappy application
we go into settings and we go on the
roles public and we look at contact we
could see that we have this update and
it's great that uh I remember to do this
because we do need to enable this so if
I click on update and click the check
boox you're going to see that we need to
make a put request to our API contacts
endpoint and pass the ID and that's
exactly what we're doing so I'm going to
save this back in my code notice that's
exactly what we're doing and we're
passing our data and our updates and
let's now import this inside our edit
and so we could import it from our data.
server and so now and there's a typo
here that's why it's complaining boom
thank goodness for our typescript and so
now everything I think looks pretty good
so let's give it a test so I'm going to
go to new test I'm going to click edit
and I'm going to say Joe Mary at Joe
Mary Twitter and then did this work and
let's click click save you define an
action route in contact added but it did
not return anything so let's take a look
here so we want to return the redirect
that's why I was complaining so let's
try this again let's go back refresh
notice the update still worked but let's
try to go uh go to Paul Bratz let's go
edit I'm going to put my I'm going to
say Kyle Bratz uh sounds good hey did
this work and and we're going to do
question mark and click save nice so we
know that our edit Works let's try it
again to do the final sity check Paul is
cool but not as cool as you all and at
coding 30 and I'm just typing random
text because whatever hello from remix
and strappy and save and perfect look at
this Paul school but our school as you
coding 30 and so our update works so
before we move on to the next step which
is write our delete functionality and
then write our star functionality let's
kind of quickly review what we did so
inside our edit. TSX file we created our
loader and our action and our form now
to populate our form with initial data
we used our loader function to get that
data based on the params so whenever
someone clicks edit you see that there's
a par R of one here that's that's the
parameter that we are getting here and
we're passing it to our get contact
method which makes a call to strappy
passing that ID returning that data once
we get that data we are using user
loader data hook and we D structuring
that data and we're using it to populate
our form with that initial data using
default values now once that's done
whenever someone hits the submit button
after making the changes that's going to
fire our action our action is going to
get the data from our form using the
request form data method then we are
passing that data to our update contact
by ID method and that expects our ID
that we use to pass to our call and our
data that we want to update we're making
a basic fetch put request to our strappy
endpoint once we get the data back and
if everything is successful is going to
go ahead and redirect if there is an
error we're going to return the error to
our front end within this form response
and for now I'm just console logging and
the reason why it's undefined is because
we didn't submit the form yet or return
any errors you could challenge yourself
to use this response and create a error
block here that if you do get an error
back you could display it to the user so
with that being said said let's move on
to the next step it's Friday night so I
needed some mood lighting but let's
continue with this tutorial so one thing
that I do want to show you when we go to
edit we have the delete button which is
kind of cool so we could press delete to
delete our entry but if you go back to
edit we do have a cancel button that
doesn't really do anything right now so
let's go fix it and the fix for this is
really easy because we want when someone
hits the cancel button it just goes back
to the original view that we had so
let's implement it now so inside our
code inside edit. TSX file we're going
to import use navigate hook here from
remix react so let's do use navigate and
we're going to scroll all the way down
to the bottom now this could be a link
and that would probably make more sense
but I want to show you that you could do
programmatic navigation through putting
a unclick event onto a button so that's
what we're going to do so we're going to
say onclick and we're just going to fire
a function that's going to use a use
navigate hook and let's just scroll up
to the top here cuz the first thing we
need to do we imported our hook that's
right and so now what I want to do
inside my edit contact component we'll
do it right below here we're going to
say const navigate equals use navigate
and what's cool right where we're going
to use navigate you can pass let's say a
URL endpoint that you want to go to
either home or contacts or if you want
to go back you could just
pass1 so very simple fix here so now
when we go back into our application if
I click edit and I click cancel it takes
me back so one more time if I click edit
and I click cancel it takes me back to
where I was okay awesome now we are
going to implement the delete button now
before we do that let's go into settings
and we're going to to enable delete and
strappy and this is going to show us the
endpoint that we want to hit so let's go
ahead first and create this function
that will delete an item from strappy so
in our code editor let's navigate to
apps data. server. TS file and just
quickly review let's look at the pattern
that we've been following when creating
these uh functions notice that we always
start with a tri catch block and we're
basically making a fetch request and if
we take a close look look to all of our
different API calls we're following that
same pattern and so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use get contacts here as
an example and I'm going to copy the
snippet and we're going to use it to
create our delete contacts so on delete
contacts let's paste that try and catch
here and we know that in order to delete
we are going to this API SL contact
slash and then passing that ID endpoint
and we know that because we saw it here
in strappy and the only difference is
instead of making a post or get request
we want to make a delete request so
we're going to say method is going to be
delete excellent and I believe that's
all we need to do here and now before we
call this function and use it let's kind
of go and look at one example here in
our routes let's go to edit so notice
whenever we were making a form
submission we were defining an action
inside that same file but you could
actually Define this action as a
standalone route so what we're going to
do we're going to create what we call a
resource route and a resource route is a
route that does not default export a UI
component so for instance I'm going to
go into routes and we're going to create
a new file and we're going to say
contacts dot we're going to want to get
the ID through the param so we're going
to say contact ID and we going just say
delete. TS I copied and paste this
example action and we're going to use it
here as well so I'm going to paste my
example action uh one thing we want to
make sure we import is our types so
import type and it's action function
arcs action function arcs from remix
node and we want to import invariant
import invariant from Tiny invariant and
and we don't need the form data or the
data all we're going to do here is await
our delete method and we're going to
import from our data. service we're
going to import delete contacts here so
let's do import delete contact and the
reason why I'm copying pasting sometimes
from our existing code is so you could
see that a lot of the things that we
create wants it's a pattern on that
variation and so a lot of times uh when
you create one basic functionality you
could use it as a pattern moving forward
and there's obviously other ways that
you could optimize your code so you
don't have to repeat yourself but I just
wanted to show you that there's a lot of
uh patterns that once you establish them
you could reuse a new code and basically
what we're going to do here we're going
to check if the pram exists if so we're
going to go ahead and call our delete
contact function by passing the ID of
the item that we want to delete and then
if it's successful it's going to
redirect and let's import redirect here
from node redirect and I guess let's
adjust this we'll say type in front so I
don't have to put it on two lines and if
it's successful it's going to redirect
and by the way if there's an error it's
going to be caught by our try and catch
here but for now we're going to keep it
super simple so now that we have have
our route defined so basically if we
remember
contacts. Conta id. delete actually
stands for contact SL id/ delete so if I
wanted to delete an entry and I guess
I'm not using the request here so we
could delete it I would just make a post
request to the delete action and we're
going to take a look at that next so
inside our code we're going to navigate
to to our contact contact id. TSX file
if we scroll down we're going to have a
form with an action called destroy and
this correlates to what we called the
route and notice that because you're in
contact SL Conta ID we don't need to put
the full URL here we just put the
endpoint that we want which is delete so
Norris contacts SL id/ delete contact
slid they the first two parts match so
we only want to show delete and when we
click delete it's going to make a post
request to our resource route that we
have created but before we could test
our functionality inside your Scrappy
admin panel go to settings go to users
permission plugin on the rolles on the
public and on the contacts make sure you
click delete and click click the check
box and click save to activate this
endpoint for strappy because in our code
when we click the delete button it's
going to call our delete action that we
defined in this file here that is going
to call our strappy endpoint delete
contact which is making a request to our
strappy endpoint here so that's why we
want to make sure that it's activated
now that's it is activated let's see if
it works so I'm going to delete test
user and I'm going to click delete it's
going to ask us to confirm I'm going to
say okay and oh my gosh we're at not
found what is going on so we going to
take a look at it I think I know where
we made a mistake so inside your code
inside our delete action notice here
that we are passing an ID so what is
happening we are passing an ID that no
longer exists because we delete it so
all we have to do is just erase this and
keep it this way and now this is going
to work but we're still going to have an
interesting problem so let's let's try
this again I'm going to create a new
entry test data at Twitter put the dummy
image click create so now when we delete
the entry notice right now we contacts
are 12 that exist if I click delete we
are again going to show not found so two
things we need to do number one we need
to figure out how to handle an error
such as 4 and four to not break our app
like it's breaking right now and number
two it's how do we render this empty
page for instance if we have items or
how to handle not found when there's
items that are not found notice how I'm
putting IDs of items that don't exist
and our application is just not working
so notice that we have one entry with ID
of nine because it exists we don't have
an issue if we do 10 it's going to
complain and if we just go to contacts
it's going to complain so first thing
let's fix this contact route so let's
take a look what is happening so inside
our application let's go to our browser
here and look at our routes notice how
we have contacts slid SL addit contacts
slid delete contacts slid contact SLC
create but we don't have just a contacts
route and that's why we're returning not
found because this route doesn't exist
so let's let's go ahead and create it
and it's going to be very similar to
what we did here we are going to create
a standalone route so not a parent route
so for instance if I create a new file
called
contacts. TSX is going to be a parent
route that's not what we want because
TSX this is going to be a parent round
and everything underneath here like all
these items they're going to be nested
children of that route that's not what
we want so the way we make it a
standalone route we put this Dash so
here I'm just going to create a very
basic component and we're going to call
it contact root so this will show up
when no items are
sected so let's see if that works and we
don't need to import the react here so
now when we refresh notice how this now
doesn't fail this works but if I do
navigate to anything here notice how we
still get 44 so next let's take a look
at how to handle errors in remix before
we handle Errors By the way you could
also throw not found errors and here's
an example you could do a response pass
the code and it could be for any type of
response that you want and we actually
kind of use this already so inside our
code if we look at contacts contact ID
and we scroll up here noise here we are
if there's no contacts available we are
throwing that new error and that's what
is actually causing our 44 that we see
on our page but notice how that breaks
our whole app wouldn't it be nice if we
could somehow catch errors and only
encapsulate those errors to the routes
where that error occurred so that means
that the rest of the application is
going to work so let's take a look at
our root error boundaries found in remix
root error boundaries allow you to throw
errors within a specific route so what
we're going to do we're going to use
this example and if you're following
along with this tutorial you could look
up root error boundaries and you could
find this example and I'm going to copy
it and right now we're just going to
paste it in the root of our project so
I'm going to navigate to the root of my
project and right above the app
component I'm going to paste in our
error boundary here and so there's a
couple of things we need to import so
use router error hook allows you to get
access to the errors and you import it
from react use error router error and
then we also need to do a type check so
remix gives us this amazing utility
function so let's also import that as
well from react and now our aor boundary
will stop complaining this is just a
warning I have this freaking insane uh
this extension called if you want to
hate yourself uh error lens install this
extension you're going to you're going
to hate yourself and so it just
complains all the time and this is just
a warning so it's nothing no big deal
but anyway and so now that we have our
error and and just to kind of give us a
visual representation of this I'm going
to say class name I'm going to say root
error and this is the error that's going
to be in the root of our project and we
could actually update just a little bit
I'm going to move this to a paragraph
tag here and then here we're going to
say oops I don't know how to spell oops
but is it oops like this yeah sounds
good it's game over okay so we have our
root error boundary in the root of our
project so no matter where we have the
error it's going to default to this
boundary here and let me just go to the
app CSS and add some basic styling so we
could visually see it and so in app.css
right here I'm going to do my class root
error and we're going to keep it simple
we're going to say background red and
then color white so now in our
application if we go and everything is
fine this is great but if I go to a
different route or some sort of error
ures it is going to go ahead and fire
that root aor boundary but notice how
application is actually kind of broken
because there's nothing I could do now
let's kind of see how we could improve
this but before let me add some petting
cuz that looks kind of ridiculous so
we're going to say padding I'm going to
do six Ram that sounds sounds good and
refresh nice and so we have our oops is
game over but my application there's
nothing I could do so let's see how we
could do this better so we know this is
happening on our contacts so if I want
to catch an error in our contacts what
we're going to do we're going to use the
same pattern so let me copy this here
and we're going to go to our routes
contact ID TSX and so this is where we
having an issue when there's not found
because this is where we throwing this
error so by throwing the error in our
loader we could actually catch it here
with our error boundary and we're going
to simplify this error boundary we're
going to instead of a body make this a
div and then we're going to delete all
this unnecessary stuff here we don't
need the script and let's going to do um
contact error just so we could style it
differently let's import use router
error and then is router error response
perfect and now that we have our error
let's say your contact has left the
building and we're going to adjust this
in our CSS so it's not scary looking
like our first error so let's go to app.
Cs and we're just going to add that
class and all we're going to do is keep
it friendly we're just going to give it
six six Ram so check this out going to
our project now whenever we have an
error in a specific route it is actually
just going to throw that error in that
route but notice out the rest of the
functionality still is there so that's
the benefit of having error boundaries
that you could Define in specific rout
so that way whenever your application
breaks it is not going to be your whole
app but just that part and if we wanted
to improve the experience we could kind
of create a back to safety button if you
will for instance inside our contact ID
here we could add another div and inside
this div we're going to put a button and
we're going to say back to safety and
we're going to add a unclick and this
could be a link by the way but I'm going
to show you just to review the
programmatic way of navigating in remix
so we just want to have a back button so
we're going to use navigate and to go
back to the previous URL we're just
going to do Nega -1 and for this to work
we need to import use navigate so let's
navigate and it's going to use navigate
and let's just double check make sure
that got imported here perfect so now
our airor boundary has a button so let's
see how that looks so if somebody goes
to a wrong URL you now have this uh
error boundary our application didn't
fail and we have this button that will
take us back to previous URL which was
working so this is a great way for you
to maintain great usability in your
application so now that we know how to
throw our errors we are able to update
delete before we implement the search
button and do final tweaks to our app
let's finally make this like button work
so we have this star and what we want
when we click this star we want it to
favor this or if we unclick it we want
it to unfavor this so let's see how to
do this in the next video Believe It or
Not implementing this update is going to
be easy because we already have the
foundation if you go to apps go into
data. server you'll notice that we have
our update contact by D and this is
basically what we're going to use to
update the like or dislike or star and
unstar functionality so let's go in our
application into routes and that's found
in contacts. contacts ID and we scroll
all the way down we going to have our
favorite function which is a form and if
you had to guess how can we get this of
course that's using our action function
we will be able to get the data based on
the name in our action and update it
accordingly so let's scroll to the top
and right after our loader we're going
to export a sync function and it's going
to be action we're going to need the
params and response and that's coming
from action function ARS we're going to
use our invariant function to double
check if we do have the ID and if that's
the case we're going to get our form
data which is going to await
response and I made a mistake here that
should be a request silly it's going to
to be
request. form data and this is going to
give us access to our elements in our
form now we're going to call our update
content by ID we're going to pass our
first argument which is our ID of the
item that we want to update and then the
item we want to update if we take a look
in our strappy application our content
type Builder we have favorite so this is
what we're going to update and it takes
a bullion so let's do favorite and we're
going to get it from form data. getet
and we are able to reference the item we
want to get here which is favorite and
if you're wondering where that's coming
from that's coming from here in the
bottom our name of the button is
favorite and this is where we're getting
that value so back in our action after
we get favored we going to check if it's
equal to true and if it's true it's
going to return true and if it's not
it's going to return false and that's
really all we had to do so now let's go
check it out in our Local Host now I'm
able to favorite and noris by Magic
remix updates the state here as well and
this is the power of remix is that you
don't have to worry too much about crazy
State updating and nesting uh remix like
magic just does it look at that change
the state change the state this in two
places this is in our side menu and this
is in our uh contacts SL contacts ID
route which is pretty cool and that's
the super power remix so we're almost at
the end here we got our edit working we
got our delete working we're able to add
new items we're able to update meaning
like or dislike or Star OnStar and now
finally let's Implement our search to be
able to search our items so I went ahead
and addit the rest of the folks here
into our application and all of these
users you could see are found in our
strappy instance and let's do 50 so we
could see all of our users fantastic so
this is pretty awesome we have our data
that is stored in strappy being consumed
by our remix application so now let's go
ahead and implement this search feature
and there's one thing that I want to
show you before we do that so I'm going
to create a test user and we're going to
do test test test for everything I'm
going to add my image and click create
notice that a user has been created and
I'm going to start that user but when we
take a look here we don't see our user
and the reason is strappy has pagination
by default and you could learn more
about it by going to your doc so in
Google you could just search strappy
pation docs click enter it's going to
find the search in Google go to sort and
pagination and you could read more about
it but if I scroll down here a little
bit we'll see that by default we set the
page size limit to 25 because the idea
is if you have a thousand a million
items you don't want to get them all at
once and because we have more than 25
users in our application the reason we
don't see the newly generated user
because you're only returning 25 of
those so the way you would handle this
you would Implement a whole pagination
where you would be able to navigate from
page one to page two and based on the
page you select you would get those
items that's slightly beyond the scope
of this tutorial I will make some future
tutorials that will cover that but for
today the easy fix will be for us to
change this from 25 to 50 so if I just
navigate to API SL contacts and we take
a look at the response if I scroll all
the way to the bottom we'll notice that
our pagination is set to 25 items items
but in total we have 31 so this is going
to be easy fix that we'll do first and
then we'll cover how to hook up our
search block here so let's do this so
now within our project let's navigate
into Apps and all the way to our root.
TSX file this is where we're getting our
initial contacts to populate our left
navigation so norce Rec calling the get
contacts method if we navigate to get
contacts you could either right click
and click go to definition or you could
click and go to our data. server. yes
because that's where that file is
defined I just wanted to show you that
you could find it in both ways and here
we have our get contacts function and we
have this query param that I said we
were going to come back to and just like
we alluded in our documentation here
notice how we're able to pass a query to
our response here in order to pass
additional query params for instance
Define the size of the page of course
you could use the documentation but I
just want to share with you this blog
post that is found on strappy doio in
blogs and it's called demystifying
strappy populate and filtering which
covers all you need to know to quickly
get started cuz for beginners this might
be a little bit complex if you've never
done this before but this shows you how
to populate and filter and query all the
different items that you need and the
reason why we have populate and filter
because when you're working on an
application you might have a lot of data
that you need to return but the best
practice when returning data from your
API is only get the data that you need
instead of getting everything because it
might be too much for your front end so
the idea by using popula and filtering
you're able to tell strappy what items
you want to get back that is required to
populate your front end and another
resource that is great and again I
always like to use Google because if you
not sure how to find something Google is
your friend so if you type strappy query
Builder it will bring up this nice
interactive query Builder and explain to
you how to construct queries so here's
an example of a complex query that it's
sorting in a ascending order based on
title it is filtering so it will only
get the items where the title equals to
hello and it's restricting you know to
populate certain data for instance
author field have a lot of items but
they're saying hey I don't need all the
items I just need the last name and the
first name and here as you could see
they're defining the page ination the
page size and so on which we're going to
use in just a moment and so in order to
use this human readable object notation
we do need to install a library called
Qs you could accomplish the same thing
using LHS syntax but as you could see
this is not really human readable it's a
pain and a butt to use you could find
npm Qs to find the Qs library and you
could learn more about it but basically
what it allows you to do it allows you
to write your queries in a object
notation similar to what we're doing
here which makes it much easier to
manage and more human readable so in my
application I'm going to stop the front
end and I'm going to do yarn add Q
if you're using yarn you could do npm
install Qs also because we're using
typescript it's going to ask us to
install the types as well it's not going
to complain here but it will complain in
vs code so we're just going to do that
right now so once this is finished I'm
going to do yarn add at add types Qs
perfect and then I'm going to restart my
application by running yarn Dev now
inside our code we're going to add a
question mark and we're going to pend
our query parameters here that we are
going to use so now let's navigate to
our root. DSX file and add the
appropriate changes so the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to import
the Qs Library so let's do import Qs
from
Qs now we're going to scroll down a
little bit and here we just going to
Define a simple variable called query
and it's going to use our us library
that we just installed and the method is
stringify which will take an object and
this object is going to take the screw
that we're going to use this object
notation and we only want to for now
fetch more data in our pagination so I'm
just going to copy this and definitely
read the docs to learn more or if you
have any questions just ask them all in
the comments I'm going to make sure to
be as supportive as possible in the
comments below to answer questions and
also start a separate thread on free
code Camp form just specifically to
answer questions for this tutorial so
now that we have our query instead of
page size being 10 we're going to set it
to 50 and we're going to pass our query
to our loader and I notice that our
loader is defined above so let's go and
move this above our loader so we have
this accessible nice now that we have
our query in our get contacts here we
are going to pass our query and Noti
that our typescript wasn't complaining
because if you take a look at get top
Texs we did make query optional which is
perfectly fine and it's set either as a
string or a null which is not an issue
if you want to make sure that query is
always required you could take out the
question mark and in the root if you
don't pass in the query types is going
to complain so I'm just going to keep it
like this for now and there's many ways
of doing things you're just going to
stick to the most simplest way so now
now that we are setting the page size
the previous issue that we had where I
added a new item and it wasn't being
return now that we're limiting instead
of 25 items to 50 items we should see
all the items so if I scroll down now
you see that we have our last item test
which is fantastic so now let's take a
look how we could modify our query and
this form to allow us filter our users
when we created our create form we
learned about form submissions in remix
so now let's take a look what happens if
I put a search term in here and click
enter we notice that we get a form
submission with a query program that is
sent via the get request so if we take a
look at our form in its current state in
our code here let's scroll down to our
form here we have our input whenever we
type any text and click enter it gets
submitted in our URL just like you see
here so now scrolling up to our loader
what we could do is we could get our URL
pram so we could utilize it in our
search so in our loader we're going to
get our request object and the type is
loader function arcs and now through the
request object we are able to get our
URL so we're going to save it to our
variable called URL and we're going to
say new equals URL and we're going to
use the request. URL so let's conso log
it first to see what we get console log
URL and because this is in our loader
you're going see the cons log in our
terminal and let me just say from loader
and you're probably saying wait a second
well how come we're using the loader cuz
in the past when we submitted the form
we used an action so whenever you
submitting a form and using post that
would be using the action but in our
case we are just submitting the form and
if we don't provide any method it's
going to go ahead and just use get and
whenever you get that request is cut by
the loader and that's why we able to
look for the URL so we could take out
the URL query parogram that we want to
pass to get contacts but before we get
that far let's see what we get so here
one more time I'm going to click enter
and again it's going to pass our form
pams as a query Pam in the URL and let's
check our cons log and no we have the
whole URL path with the query param we
also have our search params with the
search params so if we wanted to get the
params out of the URL we could use the
search params and so that's accessible
to us through this search Pam value so
let's go ahead and do that now so in our
loader under the URL we're going to say
con query equals our url. search params
and we use use the do get method and
we'll pass the key that we want to get
which is a q so now let's say I say Joe
and click enter noce we see Q which is I
key and Joe is our value and this is
where we see here under our search
forams we see Q as the key and Joe as
the value so that's one way to do it so
now we know that we're getting the value
now what we're going to do we're going
to pass that value into our get context
now I know earlier in the example ex Le
I showed you setting up the squarey here
inside the root. TSX file but we're
actually going to move it inside the get
contacts method here so let me just
erase the the import that we no longer
need here and what is this complaining
about loader function is only used as a
type that's right so when it auto
imported it didn't do it the correct way
so I just added type here so now let's
navigate to our get contact function and
inside here this is where we're going to
put our query and we need to import our
Qs and this we're going to just call Q
and we need to import Qs in the top so
let's do import Qs from Qs to get access
to the library so now in our get
contacts we're going to be passing our
query value like whatever we want to
query on and which is going to be the
value that comes from a search box and
we're going to pass it into our our
query object here where we use qqs and
you're probably wondering well how are
we going to use this to be able to tell
strappy to find items with a specific
search param so in strappy we have this
concept of filters so again if we go to
strappy documentation and we say uh
filtering and we take a look here we
have all the different params equals not
equals and we could use these params to
construct uh filtering options for
inance here's one example using Qs so
here we use filters and we say we want
username if a username is equal to John
or a query that we pass please return
that item and that's exactly what we
going to do in our code so inside our
query string here right above the
pagination let's add another object and
it's going to called filters and make
sure we put a comma at the end here so
JavaScript stops complaining and we want
to filter on couple of things so in our
app we have our user's first name last
name name we also have their Twitter and
so let's give our app the ability to
either search people by their first name
last name or search via the Twitter if
you take a look at the data that our
strappy API returns we have all these
different things we could search on so
we're going to select to search on first
or last or Twitter so if any of those
things match our query pram that we pass
then go ahead and return any of the
matching items and the way we're going
to do do that is we're going to use our
filters and we could use the or because
we're going to have couple of different
terms so we're going to say or and it's
an array and it's going to be an array
of objects of the items we want to check
so we want to check first and so we're
going to say if first name and we're
going to use contains and if you're like
where are you getting all this stuff um
I'll show you again in just a second uh
but for instance we're going to check
does the first name contain our query
param that we set so so whatever we type
here and we click enter notice how we
just return one entry with Paul because
it found an exact match and so the way
it works is because we're taking this
query term and we're passing it from our
form Rec catching it in our loader and
we're taking that query term and we
passing into get contacts and inside get
contacts within this filters object that
is used by strappy we're saying hey
check all the items check in the field
first and see if it contains the query
charm and we're actually going to also
check for last name last and we're going
to use this contains contains our query
string and then we also going to check
at Twitter so we want to also match for
Twitter items we're going to say
contains Q uh perfect and so now when
we're sending a request we're checking
VR filter ramps to check does the first
name contain the query string or does
the last name contain the query string
or does a Twitter handle contain that
quer string and so now if we go back in
our application and let's say we go back
to regular where we're not uh using any
so for instance let's say I want to find
Monica powels I should be able to type
Monica and click enter and boom It Go
will go ahead and show her if I remove
the query let's say I want to find
someone by last name let's say Lee I
could do Lee Enter and then let's back
or if I want to find someone by the
Twitter handle I could do at coding 30
that's my Twitter handle so when I click
enter go here you go it goes and uh
finds me so you could see that we're
able to search either by first name last
name or the Twitter but the experience
is still terrible I still have to type
in my search right like um John and hit
enter wouldn't it be awesome if we could
just start typing and it will
automatically search and make a request
to find that item so let's go ahead and
see how to do that next and the coolest
part about this right now I went ahead
and I disabled JavaScript so right now
right now our JavaScript is disabled and
I'm going to continue blocking
JavaScript because I want to show you
something cool here so our application
will still work because it doesn't rely
on JavaScript and that is the cool part
about remix this whole concept of
progressive enhancement so you could get
majority of of your functionality to
work without JavaScript and then you use
Progressive enhancement to improve the
user experience and I think it's kind of
cool and you could definitely look up
more about this through reading on remix
documentation or just Googling
Progressive enhancement but that is
pretty pretty awesome and pretty
ecstatic so now let's synchronize our
search value inside our search box to
our URL pram and what I mean in here if
I type Paul right now for instance and
click enter it's going to go ahead and
find Paul of course and we have this
query string and if I type John it's
going to go ahead and uh look for
anything M matching John but what if I
type a value here let's say Lee and
click enter norce we're able to find Lee
but we don't see this value inside our
search box so let's go ahead and add
that first so inside our root. TSX file
in inside of our loader function we're
going to return our contacts but we're
also going to return our quer pram which
will be available to us and let me
rename this to Q just to make it much
simpler here and we will have to adjust
this by the structuring our contacts and
our
query and now inside our form we're
going to say default value it's going to
be either Q or on empty string and let's
see if that worked we could type Paul
click enter great we found Paul now
let's say if I type Lee here Lee Enter
notice that it updates our UI so there's
still one issue we have notice how we on
John and if I switch back the URL
changes but the search program inside
the search box doesn't change it only
changes when I hard refresh but we don't
want to do that we want this to be done
automatically so so let's fix this by
using a use effect let's import our use
effect so let's say import use effect
and that's from
react and we're going to scroll down
here inside our app after contacts we're
going to say use effect which is going
to take another
function and what's cool in remix we
could make this form be a controled form
or keep it uncontrolled form the way it
is if we were to make this a controlled
form in order to get this value we would
have to use State and do something value
equals set value and then do this way
but you could actually just stick to
JavaScript so one way to get the data or
the value of this form is just by using
JavaScript and getting it based of this
ID and that's exactly what we're going
to do in our use effect so we're going
to say const search field equals
document. getet element by ID and that
ID is going to be Q so that's going to
give us access to our form element or I
should say our input element that we
have here we're going to do a little
type check here we're going to say if
search field is instance of
HTML input element then let's use it and
so we're going to get the value or set
the value I should say by saying search
field. value and it's going to be equal
to either our query param or an empty
string perfect and let's set our
dependency which is going to be our our
query Pam and this should fix our issue
so let's go back and check it out so now
in our app when I use the back button
before when our search field wasn't
being updated with our current selected
data now it does so which is pretty cool
so now let's finally add the ability to
submit our form when we are typing which
currently is not what happening so now
in our root. TSX file let's scroll down
back to the form and currently we take a
look at our form the only way we're able
to submit it is by by hitting the enter
button but what we want to do is submit
our form programmatically when values in
the form change and so what we're going
to do we're going to use unchange prop
this is going to take a function that's
going to currently be blank right now
and remix has a use submit hook that
allows you to programmatically submit a
form so let's go ahead and import it so
here we're going to say you submit and
scrolling down inside our app component
let's do const
submit equals use submit and now we
could use our submit method here inside
our form and the unchange we're going to
say submit and inside we're going to get
our event and let me move this down to
another line so it's easier to see and
from our event we're going to get
current Target so this is going to get
the value from our form so let me
refactor that a little bit so perfect so
now anytime our form changes we are
going to to fire this submit method
that's going to go ahead and
programmatically submit our form so
let's see if that works so in our
application I'm going to type PA and
notice how now every time our form
changes we are able to
query our search which is pretty awesome
So currently when I am typing things to
search we don't have any visual
representation that something is
happening so if we had a slower Network
so let's go ahead here into Network and
say we have a very slow 3G network and
so any Ty I type something notice how it
takes a while to search for the item so
let's go ahead and improve the
experience by adding a loading spinner
and we're going to reference the
documentation uh to see how to do this
and in remix we have the used navigation
hook which gives us some feedback so
let's go ahead and use it so what we're
going to do is first import the use
navigation hook so after submit we're
going to say use
navigation and then inside our app
component we're going to do cons
navigation is equal to use
navigation and then we can also do
navigation Dot to kind of see all the
things that we have access to for
instance we have form action form data
form methods and so on and then we also
have this access of state which tells us
if we are submitting if it's idle or
loading so we have all these useful
methods that we could use so for the
particular example here we're going to
use navigation location and we're going
to check if the query has a query
parameter to identify if we're currently
in searching state so when there's
nothing's happening as you could see
here navigation location will be
undefined but when the user navigates it
will be populated with the next location
while data loads so let's go ahead and
implement this so we're going to say
const searching is equal to
navigation
location and and we going to create new
URL search params
nav location search and then we're going
to check if it has our query so now
let's go ahead and utilize this in our
form so we're going to scroll down to
input and we already have the CSS set up
so here we're going to say class name
and we're going to say if searching then
we're going to append the class loading
and if we're not loading just have an
empty string and here currently our
spinner is hidden but now let's only
make it hidden if we're not searching
nice so this should do the trick so just
quick review in the searching variable
we're able to use navigation location to
check if we're currently in searching
state if so we're going to use it here
in our input so if we are searching
we're going to change our class to
loading which is going to style our
input appropriately and same thing here
for our spinner which is currently
hidden if we're not searching but if we
are searching it's going to show so
let's go ahead and test it in our
application so now when I start typing
so notice how you could see the spinner
happening when we're loading this is
pretty cool so now let's see how we
could improve our search functionality
and referring to remix documentation
they have a bit here called managing the
history stack and what is happening
since the form submitted on every
keystroke typing each character and then
deleting it will create a huge history
stack as we could see in this example so
to prevent this let's see the changes
that we could do so here we could use
replace in submit so let's search
replace us props and as you can see here
what replaced does it replaces the
current entry in history stack instead
of pushing a new entry which is exactly
what we need in this use case so let's
go ahead and implement this in the code
so so let's scroll down and make the
following changes in our function that
we're passing to our unchange so the
first thing we're going to do we're
going to put it in the brackets and
above the submit we're going to create a
const and we're going to call it is
first
search and we're going to say if query
is equals to null then it is first
search then inside of our submit method
here we're going to pass a set second an
argument and we're going to say replace
and we're going to say exclamation point
is first search fantastic so now that
should fix our history stack issue and
everything else should work accordingly
so now when we start using our search
instead of creating a new item and
pushing it to our history stack instead
it's going to replace it which is
awesome so pretty much we're done with
all of our basic implementation so let's
review what we've done quickly and then
see some of the basic improvements we
could add before finishing this tutorial
so we implemented full crud
functionality using remix and strappy
our front end is built with remix and
our back end is built with strappy where
we are able to manage our users database
and information inside of our front end
application we're able to create a new
user free code Camp if I try to create a
form without validating required fields
we get our validation which we used Zod
for which is pretty awesome so let's add
our image and our Twitter handle and
we're able to create a new item we're
also able to like or unlike our item
we're going to like it we are also able
to edit you are all awesome and safe
which will update our message and we
have our search functionality where
we're able to search the items which is
great great and we could also delete but
we'll leave free code Camp here so let's
take a look at some of the improvements
so one Improvement we're able to do is
norce when we select an item the
matching navigation item is not
highlighted wouldn't it be nice that we
could show what link is active once it's
selected for instance if I go at Paul
braslavsky this should stay selected so
let's take a look how we could fix this
so in our code if you navigate to our
root. TSX file and we scroll down to our
link we have couple of different classes
that we're able to add so inside a CSS
that was provided with this project we
have a class called active if we take a
look at what that looks like and again
because right now we're not checking to
see which link path is matching so it's
going to highlight all of them but you
could see that we have a highlighted
active class and we also have a pending
class meaning it's pending to load so if
we take a look you see this nice pulsing
animation so what we could actually do
in remix we have a component called Nev
link and Nev link allows you to pass a
function to your class name which is
going to have two states and the
function is going to have a state is
active and another state called is
pending so what we could do is return if
the item is active let's show the active
class and if it's not active and it is
pending let's show the pending class
otherwise it's going to be an empty
string now the reason why this is
complaining because we need to import
our Nev Link at the top so let's
navigate to the top and after use
navigation we're going to say Nev link
so now if we scroll back down notice how
we're no longer having issues so now
let's take a look at our UI so notice
since I'm on Paul Browski the route
matches it's active so it's highlighted
if I switch to Shane Walker notice how
it's highlighted and because we're
loading things fairly quickly we don't
see the pending state so let me go ahead
and Throttle Down by going to network
and say throttling and use slow 3G noise
when I switch now we have that pending
State until the item loads which is
pretty awesome so another Improvement we
want want to make is for this star and
unstar function currently we implemented
it using regular remix form submission
which is okay but because we're not
navigating and just want to change the
data instead of using just the regular
form we could use use fetcher so let's
take a look at remix documentation to
kind of see what this means so we could
actually have forms without navigations
and this is where use fetcher comes in
it allows you to communicate with the
action and the loader without causing
navigation which happens automatically
when just using form and since we're
remaining on the same page and we don't
want to change pages and just when to
get the data use fetcher is the perfect
fit let's go ahead and use fetcher in
our code so in our project let's go to
apps and routes and let's navigate to
our contact id. TSX route and first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to import fetcher up and I miss the
first time so action function arcs this
should be a type if we didn't make that
change before but now let's go ahead and
here import use
fetcher and now let's scroll all the way
down to the bottom until we get to our
favorite component here and inside here
let's do const fetcher equals use
fetcher and the only change we need to
do is instead of saying form we are
going to say fetch your form and that's
the only change we have to make so now
the form will no longer cause navigation
but simply fetch the action and fire the
logic required to update our star state
in the database so if we go back to our
application notice how everything still
works the same and next finally let's
take a look how we could throw errors if
something happens to our back end so in
our application let's go to data. server
and we're going to look at get contact
and notice how we have a try and catch
and if everything goes well and smoothly
from strappy we will return our data
including strappy errors but if this try
and catch block fails we want to return
an error here and we know whenever we
throw an error it is going to be caught
by our error boundary and we have couple
of them in our application but we're
going to take a look at the one inside
our root. set x file and here we have
our error boundary and whenever there's
an error that's thrown we have an error
what I'm going to do just simplifies
this a little bit I'm going to delete
this H1 so instead we only get the
messages that are delivered from our
error and I'm going to make this an H1
so before we throw an error just want to
make a note here and you could search
error sanitization in the remix docks
with in production mode any error that
happens to be on the server are
automatically sanitized to prevent
leaking any sensitive information such
as Tech traces to the client this means
when we use and throw a new error the
instance of a error that we receive
using use router error hook will be a
generic message and no stack Trace so
one way we could throw errors is by just
doing throw new error with some message
so let's check this out so in our
application in our route. TSX file we
are calling the loader where we getting
contacts so let's go to get context
within our data. server. TS file and
here in our try and catch blocks right
after the conso log we're going to throw
a new error oh no something went wrong
so if there's a server error or
something is wrong this will be cut in
this catch block which will throw an
error and depending which route this
error cured will'll use the appropriate
error boundary and in this case this is
going to happen inside the loader in
root. TSX file which is going to use
this airor boundary so now let's say if
we go to our data. server file and let's
say we don't pass a URL and boom Oh no
something went wrong and where is that
text coming from it's coming from our
data. server from this thrown new error
another way you could throw errors is
using the response object so we take a
look at the documentation you could
throw a new response including the
message that you want with the status
code so I'm going to go ahead and
replace it here just so you could see
another variation so now not only are we
sending the response message but we're
also returning the status if I refresh
noise how we getting the 500 error one
thing you may notice when we had our
error we just showed the status of 500
but how do we display the text so going
back to our root. TSX inside our error
boundary we are getting the error using
the response and pass the 500 and we are
able to see the status let's take a look
at what the error object looks like
before we see the changes that we need
to make so before we figure out what's
going on let's go ahead and conso log
the error object so now I'm going to
refresh and we get our error object if
you look we take a look that our status
text is blank but we get our message
within the data so two ways to fix this
one thing you could do is inside the
error boundary here you could do an or
statement which will basically say if
status text is an empty string return
error. data and that's going to fix the
issue so if we go back here and I
refresh norce we getting our message
another thing that you could do is
inside the data. server file after
status you could do status text and you
could add a custom message this is
custom error and that would work as well
so let's take a look if I refresh and
notice we get this is my custom error so
now you have two ways to throw errors
you could either use throw new error or
use throw a new response and now that we
finally know how to throw our errors
this bring us to the end of our amazing
journey you did it thank you on
embarking this journey with me of
learning remix Basics and strappy and
the most important part what we learned
today about remix about basic usage of
strappy you could now start building
cool things my biggest goal for myself
is to build things quickly as easily as
possible and I hope you could see how
combining remix and strappy allows you
to do that this was just the beginning
tutorial so there's definitely a lot
more to learn you could check out my
channel coding after 30 I have a great
strappy crash course that you could take
for absolutely free and if you really
like this tutorial here on free code
camp and you want me to make more
tutorials just smash the like button let
me know in the comments if you want me
to make tutorials here on free code Camp
I I really believe in free education and
I am more than willing to share
everything I know about web development
as someone who switch careers late in
their 30s into development to share here
on this channel and if you have any
questions let them know in the comments
also you could go to the GitHub of this
project where I shareed the link at the
beginning of this video and you could
create an issue with your question and
I'll make sure to help an answer and
I'll also once this goes live on free
code Camp I'm going to make sure to
create a thread on their Forum so that
way I could talk with you and help you
with this course because I'm not AI
generated and I am a human I might have
made a mistake here or there and so you
find one please let me know and I'll fix
it as soon as possible but with that
being said thank you so much for coming
on this amazing ride with me and
learning remix and strappy with that
being said I'll see you in the comment
section take care